des appareils de musculation au repos
forcé de plus le 15 mars dernier les
1000 clients de cette salle de sport de
guyancourt ne peuvent pas venir
transpirer à cause de l'épidémie de
corolla virus une situation compliquée à
gérer financièrement pour les
responsables ces derniers doivent
notamment rembourser certains clients
ont leur proposer des offres
on estime aujourd'hui la profession
avoir perdu entre 30 et 50% du chiffre
d'affaires sur l'année 2020 ce qui est
une perte assez colossal de plus on n'a
pas de visibilité comme je vous le dis
donc pas de l'information à donner à nos
adhérents parce qu'on peut pas les les
informer sur la date éventuelle
d'ouverture cette pause a également des
conséquences sur le matériel ces
machines sont d'ordinaire utilisé des
dizaines de fois par jour
ça nécessite de l'entretien qu'il faut
continuer à les faire fonctionner à voir
si tout est opérationnel pour la
réouverture aussi c'est important les
lubrifié vraiment réparer les petites
les petites choses entre guillemets la
bonne nouvelle c'est que voilà on n'a
plus le temps de se plonger vraiment de
plus en détail sur chaque machine pour
continuer à créer du lien avec les
adhérents pendant cette période la salle
a décidé de muscler sa stratégie en
mettant en place des cours sur internet
mais également des cours en extérieur du
pilote déconfinement depuis le 11 mai vu
que le gouvernement a réautorisé des la
pratique sportive à l'extérieur maximum
10 personnes on a effectivement ouvert
des cours collectifs limité donc à neuf
adhérents plus le coach et avec bien
entendu la distance en social du gel
hydroalcoolique à disposition la
désinfection du matériel
après et avant utilisation les gérants
espèrent désormais une réouverture pour
le 2 juin prochain pour retrouver un
second souffle